hello I'm Ryan jety I'm the founder of
Spectra Studios we are in Urban Design
architecture and game development Studio
based in sanan Puerto Rico uh I began my
career in New York City uh I have a
masters in urban planning and I worked
for the New York City Department of
Transportation in the bike and
pedestrian Planning Group uh so I got to
uh be there at a time when we were
installing about 50 miles of bike Lanes
each year uh and I got to work on really
cool projects like the CL of Time Square
to automobile traffic uh and the
creation of these really great public
plazas uh and amazing public space uh I
left uh the dot uh to found social
bicycles which later became jump bikes
and we released uh dockless bikes and
later electric bikes and scooters in
cities all over the world uh until we
acquired by Uber in
2018 uh where we were able to scale up
uh internationally and integrate our
bikes into their app uh through that
process I really learned uh through both
both experiences how hard it is to
change existing cities uh particularly
when they look like this uh as is the
case in the United States where you have
low density single family homes you have
strip malls you have office Parks
surrounded by parking and nothing else
and then even when you have downtown
Towers often at the street level you're
just confronted by parking garages these
are spaces that are fundamentally built
for cars and we tried to bring bikes to
a lot of those places Atlanta Phoenix
Orlando Tampa Los Angeles Houston uh and
it's really really hard to uh to to to
adapt and introduce new Transportation
when the land use is so
broken um so I spent a lot of time
thinking about what would I do if I
could build from scratch what would be
the ideal city what what kind of things
am I interested in I spent 20 years
thinking about this uh and you know I
think it begins with midrise mixed juice
density so two to seven story buildings
residences up above uh shops and
restaurants on the ground floor streets
that are narrow and really really great
for pedestrians of all ages um you know
streets like what you'll see here in
Amsterdam uh which are not only great
for pedestrians but great for bicyclists
that uh you can actually use it as a a
primary form of transportation and it's
not just uh you know Weekend Warriors
wearing light uh wearing spand decks and
and helmets that it's really a viable
form of transportation for for children
for women and and for the elderly um and
I love this Urban form and I I really am
inspired by those types of cities but I
also like the introduction of some
Towers I don't I don't think like a a
Skyline dominated by Towers but it is a
very magical experience where you're
walking through a a mid-rise
neighborhood you turn a corner and you
catch a glimpse of a tower out in the
distance and it gives a sense of scale
and ambition that I think adds a lot of
value to a city um and the last thing I
think about is how do you integrate
Green Space into a city not just large
Parks but little neighborhood pocket
Parks Greenways or something like The
High Line in New York City uh where
you're actually given an elevated
perspective you're on the second level
level you're weaving in and out of
interesting buildings you're catching uh
views of skyscrapers so you know these
are the thoughts that have been swirling
around in my head for a very long time
as I visited different places and was
really looking for a place to experiment
and so the idea behind Spectra uh is a a
virtual using virtual reality to test
urban design ideas uh and and you know
we used it to build a concept City that
we explored a lot of these um types of
urban form uh and the goal is to
actually build a real Physical City of a
million people uh so not just like a
small town or a village but a true City
scale project which will take decades
and decades to achieve but you can
actually simulate and test it virtually
first and then importantly not just
creating a top- down vision for that
City but allowing the Bott Bottoms Up
formation of the city so really thinking
about it block by block and allowing
groups of 100 to 200 people to form
blocks and then in Virtual space move
those blocks around the city and so that
you're uh uh you know while you're still
in the virtual uh world you can move
things around you can change it and you
can test different ideas and so we
wanted to come up with an architecture
that matches that philosophy that you
could have you know smaller groups of
people 100 to 200 people take over a
block and customize it so we came up
with this simple design concept uh it's
just an a building and a bu building
that clip together like Legos uh they
have a shared interior Courtyard that
can be customized it has a a ground
level that can be changed and customized
it has rooftop gardens but you have all
the building blocks of a great City in
one simple repeatable concept and the
idea is that each block each each group
of 100 to 200 people can choose what
their Courtyard and what their L1 looks
like and so this is the idea of like a
sports block where you have you know
basketball court swimming climbing
climbing wall um but you could also
Imagine Concepts that are organized
around young children or food or music
or whatever the interest of those blocks
are uh and so that the residents uh can
just can choose how much to uh treat it
as amenity Space versus commercial and
rentable
space and you get a really wide uh
diversity of of building types even
using a simple template uh by making
subtle changes so for an example here if
you drop a corner corner building unit
now the interior Courtyard spills out
onto the street so as you're walking
block after block even if it's sort of a
a templated city it feels really
different and interesting as you explore
it and you'll also notice here at the
street level there's no cars uh the idea
is that uh you know you can actually
build a tunnel network uh if you're
doing it from from the very beginning by
connecting the basements of all these
buildings so if you're trying to build a
tunnel in an existing City uh in San
Francisco I think they're about to spend
$8 billion on a one mile tunnel uh but
if you're doing it when you're laying
the infrastructure from the beginning uh
you just connect the basements with like
small pass uh small underground tunnels
between the streets um and it's much
easier to build that out and so you
could have your Logistics movement your
packages all of that happening in an
autonomous Network
underground um and finally yeah having
some of these elevated viewpoints uh
like the Highline where the courtyard
level is connected across each block and
so you can actually explore the entire
city in more of like a garden or a
Parkway uh uh a Greenway type of
environment uh so if the streets are too
busy with with bicycles and scooters uh
you could actually kind of escape to
more Park Lake environment and so all of
these ideas are wrapped up into a kit of
Parts um so the idea is we we release
this under a Creative Commons license
anybody could take these ideas bring it
into their own game environments or or
do their own Urban Design
experimentation ideally feed back to
this and we can create a concept city of
all of these different components uh
move it around change change the uh get
feedback on the idea and then eventually
find a piece of land and build um so
since we launched publicly in January
we've hosted over 20 workshops in the
Virtual City uh this is a a workshop
that we hosted in partnership with a
German research University that has a
large European Grant to do research in
the Virtual City uh We've hosted uh you
know some on agriculture some on on bike
transportation a variety of different
workshops to get feedback on the concept
and whenever I show up at a a conference
or event or even just a bar I I break
out the laptop and uh you know get
people to be immersed in the virtual
world now I've been thinking about you
know how do we go beyond just you know
hosting events in the virtual space and
how do we introduce some game elements
uh and so we've come up with the game
that we're going to be releasing next
year called Yim NIMBY War the idea is
that everybody here is going to come
across nimes when you try to build your
project the not in my backyard people
and so they are possessed by these
demons these bad ideas and you have to
Vanquish them uh and shoot them down and
Liberate the people
uh and and
so and and so just introducing a little
bit of light gameplay to get people idea
like how hard it is to build a city and
the think that we have to overcome uh
lastly uh I'm really excited by the
stuff we're doing in the digital world
but I want to undertake a physical
project much like what we seen today
from cabin and neighborhood and Nomad
and all these folks uh so I I we've
purchased a 80 acre piece of land in
Puerto Rico um we want to turn it into a
working organic farm and a Hospitality
concept for group travel so something
that would be a perfect venue to host
these 5050 to 100 person meetups and
micro conferences um so it's got a a u a
co-working space uh a gym uh Child Care
Facilities uh podcast recording studio
uh so we've we've designed these two
buildings and put it through the same
process of Designing virtually uh
applying it to a piece of land and
trying to build a community around that
um and so yeah we're we're trying to
make a really the best place for large
groups to come together and hang out
it's got these two uh common buildings
these these sort of shared buildings
with all the the programming uh and and
then we're designing uh these Bolognese
style
Villas uh with six bedrooms uh so you
can actually stay here we're going to
have four at least four of these on the
property uh so that's 24 bedrooms so
we're at a really good size for hosting
these events of like 50 to 100 people
and so that's a it's one it's practicing
this virtual the physical process and
two it's it's thinking about how do we
create this engine of bringing groups of
of 50 100 200 people together that could
become the seeds uh for a city of the
future that we might build
um and so that's it so this is a
timeline a little bit about what we've
accomplished so far um plan to Again
release the first game in the first half
of next year uh and uh submit uh the
designs and site plan for the
entitlements and start building the
physical site uh you know ideally being
Construction in early 2025 so uh thank
you so much and uh
yeah